subway the restaurant is it a restaurant
I don't know what it is that place where
they have some food and the footlong and
the six inch and all thing they you know
they've been pushing themselves as this
healthy alternative they took that fat
slob Jared and turns him just into like
an average bum but now it turns out that
their stuff is not much healthier than
then even McDonald's according to a
study at UCLA there's as much sugar carb
sodium and overall calories and like
half the stuff on their menu is this the
worst thing that could possibly happen
to Americans even subway even subway the
one thing we were told was healthy is
also going to kill us I think I think
their tagline is eat fresh well it
doesn't say eat healthy they're there i
think americans like i mentioned earlier
we're a bunch of dummies and so we
automatically assume that these are subs
these I grew up in Jersey yeah I mean a
sub is not a healthy thing right since
when did it get healthy and plus it's
not even if these are all prepackaged
okay when they bring that meat out of
the package you ever see that and they
have a cheese steak on the menu a
cheesesteak there's no way that could be
healthy but yeah you could go to
McDonald's and get a salad if you really
want I don't know anybody that does that
why would you go to McDonald's to get a
salad yeah and actually McDonald's just
dumped some of their salad so probably a
good idea nobody goes to McDonald's
first that works out but yeah it's a
Subway sandwich is basically just it's a
it's a hamburger in a longer bun yeah I
just I'm shocked it's something that you
can get at a gas station is not good for
you just shock yeah you never fill up
your tank get a footlong to go and feel
like you're doing something right well
look I'm a comic on the road and
sometimes when you're in you know
scratch your butt Arkansas no offense
Arkansas but that sometimes your only
option
yeah you know so yes of course I've had
to have subway but i never thought i was
eating healthy never not for a second
i thought it was the lesser of two evils
i'd rather do that than just you know
fast food but I was never fooled that's
something I could get at inside they
have them in
side of gas station literally Enzo and
they're always next to like a Taco Bell
and they share the same counter like no
one here is are we really being fooled
that this is healthy yeah it might be a
little healthier because look there's a
pickle but that that's about it that's
about it
is there anything scarier than that
combo store what is it it's its subway
is it Pizza Hut and Taco Bell is that
what it is though yeah it really really
is
and sometimes you have to do it and
you're in Jersey I whenever I'm in
Jersey I always find myself on those you
know those rest stops that are always
kept and and when you walk in it's just
Here I am in in the depression court
they they call it a food court but it's
the saddest place it's Joey
sad it is and so you just go in and like
I just have to eat something but I'm not
fooling myself none of this is really
nourishing my body's just so don't die
in Jersey that's really basically it
right so if there was like an actual
healthy version of this and we see some
of this stuff popping up like an energy
kitchen kind of thing would it fly in
America it feels like it never really
takes off these like sort of healthier
things they appear and then they just
kind of disappear because Americans like
our salt that's exactly it so that is
exactly it you can you can say look this
is healthy but Americans like food to
taste a certain way and it has to have a
certain write of bad fats with that salt
and that sugar I mean there's sugar in a
lot of food that you don't think you
wouldn't ever think there's sugar and
why but they need those preservatives or
something inside of us now in our tissue
almost like our DNA we're a healthy food
does not taste good to the average
American it just doesn't do you have a
personal policy on this on how you go
about this report they studied like a
hundred 12 year olds right I mean at
home isn't gonna go in there and say can
I have the wheat scooped out with just
turkey and a little bit of like no
they're gonna go for like the biggest
baddest sandwich on the menu yeah I
think as you get older you know as
things start to drop a little bit on
your body as the metabolism starts to
slow down you make healthier choices
but you know twelve-year-olds not gonna
walk in there and ask for the you know
grilled chicken on a on a on a wheat bun
yeah okay guys all right I try to I try
to run a nice shiny coat that's all the
makeup you do have a nice shiny nice
shiny coat right yeah and speaking of
healthy choices I've enjoyed having you
guys on the show and I'm gonna let you
guys pimp yourselves out because I feel
comedians can always do that more
effectively than I can possibly do that
so you could talk to camera three right
there you got 10 seconds kara go well
don't go to my facebook page cuz already
told you what I think about those people
so Twitter at cura comedy and website is
kira comedy calm and check out the
mother funny show does he go I host a
podcast called decently funny so go to
decently funny calm it's a lot of fun I
just had Jason Biggs on my show enjoy
that and on Twitter at the nosy all
right and I'm Dave Rubin I hope you know
where to find me at this point out Rubin
report on Twitter and click like and
share and all that good stuff and fight
with us down there we'll look at them
and review them and send them to Keira
for the KGB to take care of the rest of
it ok thanks guys we'll do it again next
week
[Music]